[Music]
companies are complicated investment is
tricky predictions are hard to make
especially about the future what's
needed are local guards who tried to
point investors in the right direction
we have them in the form of securities
analysts these professionals typically
work for brokers investment banks and
fund managers they do statistical
analysis and talk to company bosses
recently they seem to have been in
retreat what's gone wrong for them first
regulation has tightened up customers
have decided fewer analysts are needed
second investment is changing customers
who are mostly active managers are in
retreat 2/3 the focus of big business is
shifting companies are beginning to see
a purpose broader than shareholder value
many analysts specialize in valuations
based on next year's profits that's an
important skill but a narrow one our
securities analysts doomed our analysts
now is obsolete as diesel cars or
cassette players let's consider each
challenge the regulatory hit comes from
method 2 in the EU commentators have
likened it to the trifid a fictional
man-eating plant before method to fund
managers routed their trades to a broker
to execute on the market in return
brokers charge commissions that included
the cost of research received by the
fund manager method 2 required fund
managers to disclose this cost to their
clients embarrassed they decided they
needed less of it the trend is spilling
over into the US other changes are
thinning the ranks of securities
analysts index funds which passively
track market benchmarks are growing fast
PwC forecast index funds will account
for half the u.s. total by 2025 but Lex
thinks reports of the death of the
securities analysts are exaggerated
here's why stana lists lined to societal
changers doomed is any other
professionals those who adapt
they can calculate discounts on oil and
gas reserves due to climate change for
example index funds have made smaller
inroads than warriors imagined and their
share of the US stock market is only 13%
moreover part of the justification for
index funds is misleading
they are certainly low cost and may
appear to remove human error but in
reality hit next compilers can still
make bad choices they could trap
investors in weak sectors gain downturns
when it could increase financial
instability finally people will always
need other people to study the numbers
behind investment UK and u.s. brokers
may require fewer analysts other
employers may want more data from the
CFA Institute show demand to take it's
tough exams is rising sharply in Asia
and is steady elsewhere the Securities
analyst is dead long live the Securities
analyst
[Applause]